bishop Marian edgert buddy joins us now
to discuss this story bishop thank you
so much for joining us this morning I
want to start with your comments
yesterday I heard you use a word outrage
normally that's a very strong word to
use I'm curious about when did you first
find out the president was coming how
did you find out and what bothered you
most about it I had no prior warning and
so I was sitting on my couch with my
mother watching The Evening News when my
phone started ringing and people
contacted me to let me know what was
happening what disturbed me most was the
first of all that the context which
you're which are reporting described
that after speaking so harshly and with
militaristic overtones to the nation he
he he had the park of peaceful
protesters cleared with tear gas and
offers is in riot gear to to make a
symbolic gesture holding a Bible as if
to spiritually condone a message and a
posture that is antithetical to the
teachings of Jesus and everything that
we as a church stand for I want to say
to the audience there's a bit of a delay
but the bishop and I can hear each other
but there is a bit of a bit of a delay
Bishop what would have made his trip to
the church okay with you if he had come
to church to pray if he had come to
acknowledge the grief and the outrage
that people are feeling at yet another
senseless brutal killing of an
african-american man at the hands of a
white police officer if he had come to
speak a word of healing to acknowledge
that as your own reporting has suggested
the deep roots of racism that are at
that are that are at at the heart of
this agony if he had spoken a word of
hope to the thousands upon thousands of
young people who are wondering how they
can how they can live into their future
any of those things
would have been a welcomed gesture on
the part of our president but not not a
symbolic misuse of the most sacred texts
of our tradition and the backdrop of our
church you are not the only one we
should say this morning using the word
outrage but a lot of the president's
allies are saying it was a show of
strength what is your response when you
hear that I think the kind of strength
we need is the kind of strength you you
exhibited with the Houston Police Chief
who walked alongside his people and
acknowledged their pain and said that he
would stand with those who are seeking
justice and change and when you when you
enter into that kind of posture and
relationship with people you are
immediately given credibility and a
place to be heard that's the kind of
message that that we all need in the
leadership that we are looking for I
know you've spent 18 years working as a
rector in Minneapolis you know this city
very well when you see these pictures
what are your thoughts about what's
going on in your former city how is it
personally affected you
well personally it is one of the great
heartaches of my life I have family
there I have deep friends I know
something of the deep racial divides of
that city that are historic and embedded
in the institutions of that of the city
and of the state and so so all of that
and yet the the the deep desire of so
many to bring about change and and the
violence that is erupting is it's
devastating but the fundamental cause of
the pain is something that we all must
look at and almost address or it will
keep on repeating itself in City after
city and neighborhood after neighborhood
town after town in this country until we
until we look at that that primal that
primal sin of
and seek true reconciliation and justice
in our country
all right bishop thank you before you go
does President Trump go to that church
your church on a regular basis no no he
uh I mean he's rarely in church and the
only time he has been to st. John's to
my knowledge was on the morning of his
inauguration all right thank you very
much for joining us today